la directrice d'un cinéma municipal de
vitrolles licenciés motif son refus de
déprogrammer des courts métrages sur
l'homosexualité et ce en dépit des
interdictions adressiez par la
municipalité front national plusieurs
personnalités du monde du cinéma ont
vigoureusement protesté contre cette
décision
elle lance un appel contre je cite
l'homophobie le ministre catherine
trautmann soutient leur action
cette décision est respectueuse injuste
par rapport à ceux à ce qui devrait être
respectée comme travail
les en même temps marqué par par une
idéologie qui ne sait pas prendre en
compte la nécessaire ouverture que
représente le cinéma comme d'autres
formes de tout